я народився в маріуполі я там виріс я
дуже сильно любив marine за будь-яким у
мене бізнес у маріуполі був я розумів
що місто в оточенні я розумів що туди
ніхто не їздить і але там були мої
співробітники і так отримували розмовляв
своїми співробітниками і я їм пообіцяв що
я приїду та привезу вам інтернет допомогою
буду їх забирати
у той момент і просто прийняв це рішення
сподіваюся
переживаю не рвіть
але поки що їду
я би не сказав що це було важко я
тоді ще не розумів з чим я зіткнувся
[музика]
ми з хлопцями скинулися на цей намиста
грошима ми купили ми завантажилися
у момент арти мого розфарбували щоб він
був помітний на той момент це все ось
все так влаштувалась все класно і вона
швидко і ось у той момент коли я вже
виїжджав з горіхово це була українська
блокпост серед і
той момент і почав знайомитись з війною
ці міни ці танки горілі то
це весь жах до яких ти бачиш і
тоді у мене ось цей страх як ялте що
я тільки не робив дорогою молився кайл
і
у мене були біблії тут і тут дві
біблії тут 2 кохання але при цьому страх
не залишав і
я їхав
ходімо швидше покажу дещо в мене
бізнес у маріуполі був це нічний клуб
karaoke lounge bar
[музика]
тут ще 2 звуть
більшість його перебуваючи під землею
були бетонні перекриття ми зробили
бомбосховище ну я його не перевіряв на
міцність але в той момент він був
комфортною за площею тому що там був
мангал чи можемо розігріти їжу та воду
треба як настрій
настрій бомба у нас були чергування у
нас були сталкери які добували їжу у
нас були водоноси, які ходили
видобували воду тобто настільки все
налаштовано стільки правильно ми там ще
жартували щоб він був притулок 5 зірок у
нас випав сніг а це означає сьогодні ми
будемо чистими була група возами і там
додавши додати додав всіх своїх
знайомих рідних я не знав виберусь і чи
ні та я щовечора сідав я писав як
ви як ми живемо
ми їздили сусіднім бомбосховищем ми у
основному брехня з'їздити так їздити то
що ми не могли довести на машині ми
носили пішки страшно було практично
завжди чому тому що весь час
переживаючих нічого не прилетіло
це прилетіла прям
тут прилітала але все що прилітала все
попадало десь поруч ось там десь ось
тут внизу там ще
вниз
нормально
[музика]
хороша машину послав перед входом вона
так захистила нас накопичив моя розумничка
гарна ви зрозуміли тримає вибухнула
машина проїжджала машина ось і в цій
машині загинуло бабуся і ми з онуком їх
ним
прибирали бабусю його через дорогу
кров сильно
[музика]
соку ви розуміли там бомбосховища
гримить я сподіваюся що дитинство зберігається
навертати сидіти і
бояться
сподіваюся що боженька збереже
ми намагаємося
[музика]
я
із спогадом
найжахливіше що я не хотів би
побачити там я боявся це побачити це
працю дитини рік ось це я боявся більше
всього ось я намагався відводити очі від
будь-яких трупів від будь-яких купок маленьких так
у мене щодо дітей є окремий
життєвий пункт я батько 4 дітей та побачити
дитини
але те я тому я напевно я би зламався
і в цей момент я би займався я пізніше
напевно не був би тим
після авіаудару і вийшов що з машиною та
ми тоді давайте спробуємо
відремонтувати, але я її навіть не
ремонтують я просто сів у машину
повернув ключ вона завелася як прилетіла
мені бути машин окулярами різної гальма
у мене після авіаудару не було гальмувати
але тато маріуполь вони не потрібні були
тому що ти просто летів просто
їхав і без гальм туди куди тобі треба
проїжджала єдність шоу я переживав щоб
не виїхати на якийсь танк чи на
якийсь військовий джип без гальм та
в'їхати ми чекали можливості коли
з'явиться десь де не буде стоку
мінних полів ось ми виїхали першим
першим
[музика]
першої ж можливості ми виїхали
завантажилися дітьми won't вагітними
брали жінок із дітьми
не самомасажу і
ваша ручка
у
[музика]
нас було кілька людей один значок і
троє дітей я моя сестра чи подушка з
якою ми познайомилися притулок
було дуже страшно ми проїжджали мені на
танку
було багато манекенів
вбитий тут ми дітям
розповідам аніки ти
взагалі треба трохи сниться там про
постріли я не прокидаюсь я додивилася до
кінця потім прокидаюся вранці з того що
ну мені вже стає страшно ще сплять
тому але я це нікому не розповідала
коли у нас вивезли у небо
я заходжу в магазин я розумію, що вже на
підсвідомому рівні я дивлюся що мені
потрібно там умовної батареї сіли
продукти там першої необхідності або
аптечка тобто у мене вже за інерцією я
уявляю як хапали це все з полиці
і біжу поки що поки не прилетів снаряд я
сидів всередині місячної думки що я зараз
цивілізації і мені треба піти і за це
заплатити
місто було чудово він він тільки
розквітав але я дуже любив це я там
виріс
багато друзів там була та але це мій
рідне місто
драмтеатр це єдине місце, звідки я
не забирав те, що він був настільки все
комфортно та там були кімнати яких по
три сім'ї було з дітьми мені здавалося що
це але настільки це місце у яке ми
ніколи нічого не може полетіти все
розуміли що драм театр це місце де
люди ховаються від авіації він повинен
що мотивувало людину, яка в той
момент підпустила за ракету та пустив її
у це знання у вас що він той момент
відчував ось і навіщо це було робити
не прийшли нас звільняти ось чому від
нашого життя від нашого
будинки від наших рідних ось вони прийшли
просто знищити те, що ми маємо
харчування змогли зробити
більше ні 7
урок
[музика]
адже сама складно було це цілий день
відділ з бомбосховищ
їздила і ти збирав весь негатив
ввечері було найскладніше їсти ось ці
всі емоції та весь цей негатив то вони
він виходив але я сидів просто він ховався
і щоб ніхто не бачив що миша Михайло
Андрійович платить
так ще
так ми заправляємось
ось у нас додався ще один bus
називається втрата аскольда
крути на стає все більше і більше
в першу подорож я був один дивіться
поїздка напевно вже хвилин сорок я стояв
на 2 слухняно у пробці стільки стало
багато машин яких і людей які
хотіли допомогти забрати людей цього
ось путін тільки що він зробив на
це він показав усьому світу хто така хто
такі українці це така українця люди
згуртувалися
волонтерами вивезли тисячі людей на
своїх машинах і багато волонтерів не
повернулися деякі підірвалися на мінах
деякі потрапили у перестрілку у нічний
поїздки і так далі
більша частина це волонтери які
взяли машину
треба та їдуть це прості українці прості
люди
[музика]